after a year and a half of distance
learning hybrid schedules
today is pretty close to normal for
thousands of ccsd students
hector mejia live this morning at the
district's bus yard near arville and
harmon
thing is getting underway the bus is
getting turned on hector good morning to
you sir
yeah hey there good morning to you guys
and as you can see right behind me we
have the buses getting turned on right
now making sure everything is ready to
go on such a huge day
and this is one of five bus yards here
at ccsd joining us live we have jennifer
vovis
transportation director with the school
district good morning to you thanks for
having us this early in the morning good
morning how are you
great tell us about everything that's
going on getting ready for just
how many bus routes this morning well we
have approximately
about 1400 bus routes that are going out
this morning to take 123
000 students to school we're excited we
just want parents to be aware of our
protocols
every student is to be wearing a mask on
the bus and every
every and so is the drivers and there we
see one bus
rolling out getting ready for this day
tell us you guys are also starting the
school year with a bus driver shortage
and what does that mean for the district
and for pickup times
for those children waiting for the
school bus well we do have over 200
driver shortage however we have anybody
who has a commercial driver's license
is going to be driving a bus our goal is
to ensure that
every student gets to school on time
and tell us as we get ready for this big
day what do you want parents to know and
tell their children
before they leave their home so parents
please
know that there may be a delay in
service at the beginning of the day
of the beginning of the school day
because
we're just trying to work out our routes
also make sure that your students are
wearing masks
and they're mandatory on the bus and
also inside the building
correct they are mandatory on the bus
and our drivers will be marrying bass as
well
we have hand sanitizer for students at
the front of the bus so they can
um take use hand the sanitizer
at the route um sorry
no you're it's all good so we have a lot
going on buses leaving here by the
second
and tell us about the loading protocol
students will be
uh getting on you know through the front
or the back of the school bus
yes so how students load on the school
bus is they load from the front to the
back so that they don't cross each other
students from the same household sit
together and
when they unload they unload from the
front to the back
and they get wiped down between each use
and also nightly correct so our drivers
are trained to wipe down the buses and
frequently touch areas on the tops of
the seats and on the door
door handles and rails and then at night
we have a nightly disinfection process
awesome i appreciate your time thank you
so much for having us before we let
everyone go though
we want to show some of the action here
the buses still working heading out to
pick up
thousands of children all across the
valley we are waiting to talk with
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
this is where he's starting his morning
here as a lot is going on here
at the district huge day for a lot of
kids and families out there for now
i'm going to send it back over to you
guys all right hector thank you very
much the buses are getting going here
the first day of school a lot to prepare
prepare for good stuff okay
so ccsd students are